Owens professor at the Rowan School of
Public Health based there in Atlanta
Georgia at Emory University he is a
member of the National Academy of
Science Committee on the applied in
theoretical aspects of statistics and
his research involves the development of
statistical methods for Geographic data
including applications in environmental
justice epidemiology disease
surveillance spatial cluster detection
conservation biology and disease ecology
his research has appeared in numerous by
statistical statistical environmental
health and ecology journals as well as
he's authored a textbook entitled
applied spatial statistics for public
health data and so prior to us getting
dr. Waller underway I'd like to invite
you all to submit any questions that you
have for dr. Waller through the go-to
webinar questions submission system
which is located in the little console
they're also probably the right of your
screen and you can do that and then
we'll save some time at the end where
I'll read those questions off to dr.
Waller so without further ado dr. Waller
the stage is yours
great thank you it's a pleasure to be
here and like to offer my own wishes for
a happy st. Patrick's Day I hope you're
all doing very well in your office
basketball pools because it's data
scientists you should be today we will
be talking about well that's what I look
like and we'll be talking about multiple
testing bias confounding and missing
data or as a subtitle look at go
horribly wrong with my analysis I'm
going to give a little insight on
thinking about team data science and
team science in the data science setting
with a little bit of background to
distinguish between observational
experimental data and prediction versus
estimation to put this in context I've
been watching these webinars over the
last several weeks to get a sense of the
kinds of topics and and we have a lot of
people with a lot of different interests
I want to set some context we'll talk
about multiple testing bias confounding
missing data I'll try to give an example
for each and sources for additional
information and then wrap
coming back to team data science so data
science has I've been presented to
requiring skills from computer science
statistics are an application or subject
matter area which often leads to the
Battle of the Venn diagrams this is just
one example here and a couple of
postings where people have looked at
this but you can see sort of the three
scopes we've got this pinkish color
hacking skills or computer science we've
got math and statistical knowledge and
then we've got the substance area and
for in a School of Public Health it for
me it's a lot of health-related research
data science is kind of that sweet spot
in the middle then we could have more
than three directions one of them has a
7 set Venn diagram which I'd never seen
before so I thought I'd share that with
you too
the webinar series I really appreciate
the bd2k program putting this on because
it has provided and continues to provide
a forum for introduction across these
elements so if you go to data science
seminars within your own discipline you
here to tend to hear people similar
perspectives talking and I think really
where they growth is is this crosstalk
so I've really learned a lot from the
webinars and hope you're enjoying them
as well in computer science they've been
webinars on hard work just even the
basic setup of doing big data also
algorithms and statistics we've had
several on concepts techniques Bayesian
analysis and so on I think it's the
intersection of all these where the
unique and emerging issues come up and
today what I'm talking about are trying
to draw some statistical concepts from
observational studies often from
epidemiology then how these may scale up
or maybe may need to be revised in a big
data setting so we'll talk about
definitions examples and the scaling
issue primarily I think each and every
one of these as wide open for additional
work so I'm not stating that these are
problems of a statistical nature and
dropping the microphone but instead we
want to have an invitation for the
interdisciplinary work and really work
those intersections in the Venn diagram
team data science there's a lot of
interesting discussions going on at
conferences and in publications on the
intersection between these areas and one
thing I've heard recently
the discussion of whether a team of data
scientists should consist of several
people who are identical or several
people with complementary skills I tend
to favor the idea of a heterogeneous
team because it brings different
expertise and experience also different
problem-solving intuition that's a big
deal to me are people understanding what
how do they approach a problem what do
they think the cool part of it is if you
have different people on the team and
looking at that from different aspects I
think you get much more creative
analytic and interpretation perspectives
in your analysis interdisciplinary team
science can be very tricky if you want
to go all the way to transdisciplinary
collaborations I tell my students and
colleagues that I think it's a lot like
international travel when you work
interdisciplinary setting the language
is different the social norms are
different what the cool journals are is
different how money counts you know what
you should write into a grant that all
needs to be negotiated it's also a lot
like a middle school dance where you've
got multiple groups who are interested
and they know they want to interact with
each other but they're not quite sure
how to do that yet and so they tend to
cover up the insecurities with a lot of
teasing and we see that in the
publication's too of they're sort of
trying to establish your own discipline
as the key discipline in here I also
recently I don't have this on the slide
heard a definition that disciplinary
work is like an Apple interdisciplinary
collaborations like a fruits fruit
basket
interdisciplinary works like a fruit
salad and transdisciplinary work it's
like a smoothie so how did data impact
science that's our question I mean our
goal and big data and knowledge is to
take data extract information from it
and and develop knowledge so I want to
frame this in terms of questions
analytic tools and answers and this is
something we present in class a lot
geographic information systems class I
start with and I can't take credit for
this john richardson who was a
toxicologist at the EPA region 4 office
here in atlanta once said it's this
simple and he drew this picture and i
thought it was brilliant and really like
this so we start in the upper left
there's some question we want to answer
and I know in a lot of instruction
data mining there's a lot of talk about
hypothesis free analysis but I don't
think we go in completely blind I think
there are things we're interested in
finding out so they may be hard to
articulate but this first step is
articulating what you're looking for
what kinds of things you're looking for
and before running anything or before
extracting data or looking for the data
I think it's important to spend some
time thinking about what data would you
really need to answer that question
completely I do a lot of environmental
health analysis so if I were interested
in what's the impact of exposure to
drinking water near a hazardous waste
site on childhood leukemia rates I might
want to know where every child lives at
what age how much water they drink does
their house require this I could go
through a list of all the stuff I'd love
to get that I probably wouldn't be able
to but that list is a helpful mental
checklist when you take the next step
and say what data are available we have
wide variety of data types available to
us now so we can get all sorts of things
but we rarely get everything we want and
we often get proxies for things we want
like I may not know which child is
drinking from which water system but I
know where they live and I know where
the hazardous waste site is I also may
be able to find out that their that
address is listed on the county water
public water bill so I know they're
getting water to the house but I don't
know exactly what's going inside so it
tells me something but not everything so
on a lower right-hand side they I get
the data I can get and the methods I
have available I do answer some
questions as I move up to the upper
right there is what there are questions
I can answer with my data and my methods
and probably the most important step
here is to go back to the beginning and
see how close the question I answered is
to the question I want to answer and
I've presented this to many different
classes and one of the most interesting
questions I got was the student asking
me well how do you know when you're done
and my answer was well I've been doing
this for 25 30 years and so far we've
never finished any of those you get
around once and you think about what the
next step is so you keep refining and
getting closer and closer pushing those
two together but I don't know that it's
ever complete this is just
research cycle and the way I think we
want to think about our data analysis so
I also want to go into this pointing out
that our perspective as an individual
data scientist can impact what we see in
the data data science can reveal new
things so we may have some really cool
visualizations or we hook together data
to haven't been together but we also
have to be open to seeing the patterns
or the results that come out so we can
link and process Wrangell and lunge our
data but what does it really mean so I'm
gonna give a data science example from
1854 during the cholera outbreak in
London this is before the germ theory of
disease was well established so there
were the miasma people who thought it
was in the air you could smell how bad
it was in the summer and that's when it
broke out versus contagion ideas the
miasma theory at the time was that there
was bad air in the storm sewer system it
was coming out through the drain holes
and then as many of you may be familiar
with John snows work he was thinking
that it was the water from the water
pumps so this is a big data circuit 1854
this is a chart in a book referenced on
the right cartography is a disease of
the cholera outbreak in 1854 presented
at a London Board of Health and I'm not
sure if you can see my cursor but this
big curved spike on the bottom is the
number of cases of cholera along with
diarrheal disease those to follow each
other carefully everything in the
background are meteorological things
like barometric pressure and rainfall
and temperature and humidity and they
were doing on this chart a lot of what
we try to do on the computer now is try
to line up what's the magic signal that
starts off the outbreak so you know some
of the things we're doing even though
it's feels very modern this sort of
scientific inquisitive Ness with when
you're presented with lots of data from
lots of sources has been around for a
while of course the big news in 1854 was
dr. john snow and anesthesiologist who
mapped the cholera deaths in a
neighborhood and I apologize in advance
this slide has sound that was attached
to it by Carol got--we my co-author on
our book and I haven't been able to
figure how to get it out but the way the
story general
goes as snow maps maps the cases in this
particular neighborhood in London he
looks at the map he sees a concentration
of the deaths around a particular water
pump on Broad Street and says Eureka
that must be the cause
snow led an effort with others with the
London Board of Health to remove the
handle of that particular water pump so
the short version of the story this is a
snow did phenomenal work and reading
some of his papers that is highly
recommended but this has been kind of
compressed into sort of a fairy tale so
this is a travel log for London saying
in 1854 lenders were dropping like flies
from cholera until dr. snow figured out
bacteria where in the water he turned
the pump off saved countless lives and
now there's the Jon Snow pub nearby so
that's good information but it does
compress a lot of work that was going on
in a lot of controversy so we look at
this visualization of the map John snows
maps often presented as good brief if
you just map the data look at what you
can find and so it looks like a real
triumph of 1854 data science and
visualization but if you look carefully
the maps of the miasma sucked exactly
like dr. snows and if you think about
where the drain holes are they're right
by the water pumps because if your pump
leaks you'd like to have it drain out so
the maps look the same and in fact one
of the leaders if the London
Board of Health had the following
response to snows 1854 analysis and he
says this certainly looks more like the
effect of an atmospheric cause or miasma
than any other if it were in the water
why wouldn't the cholera prevailed
equally everywhere where people were
drinking the water so we've got two
different groups of people looking at
the same day - the same visualizations
now they come to a different conclusion
now history supports snows conclusion
and we see that as a triumph but it
wasn't as if he slammed the map down on
the table and everybody saw the truth so
that's a nice story what does this mean
for us a lot of data there's been a lot
of data science breakthroughs in
managing linking processing and
visualizing distributed data but you can
think about what would someone like John
Snow 1850s data scientist do with modern
computing like if you had a geographic
information system or Google or
social media well you might be thinking
he would do something like Google Flu
Trends Google Flu Trends prediction goal
was to try to beat the CDC's projection
of number of influenza like illness 'as
over a week which sort of reported
weekly and and they were doing it for a
while they were about two weeks ahead of
the CDC released numbers these are no
longer published on a regular basis
although you can still get them so what
happened is in February of 2013 the
Google Flu Trends was tweaking its
algorithm or a couple actually a month
before that and started to over predict
and in a particular week in February
they can't they predicted twice as many
cases has actually showed up so it's a
very nice summary of this it's a short
article in science by laser at all a
parable of Google Flu and I spelled flu
incorrectly or it was auto corrected so
that's I guess another bit of big data
for you the the way Google Flu Trends
works it's based on correlated searches
and so you're looking for correlations
between the kind of searches that happen
that correspond to the beginning of our
intensification of flu outbreaks and
things like high school basketball
searches for high school basketball
scores we'll start at the beginning of
the winter about the same time the flu
starts so it's not a causal connection
but it does have strong predictive power
and this has one of been one of the big
successes of Google and other data data
science development areas now that the
flu trends algorithm was proprietary and
kind of consistently tweaked and so it's
hard to say that it was wrong all along
that's not true it did very well and
I'll show you one of the plots from the
laser paper on the next slide so what
and the authors don't discount the
impact Big Data of what they do discount
as a or point out that it offers kind of
an example of big data hubris or or we
kind of ignore all everything we know
about flu and just go with the data so
this avoids the subject matter expertise
part of the Venn diagram and starts to
wander maybe not in the part labeled
danger zone but it starts to get away
from as
good a job as we could do so this
example to me is is kind of an example
against the idea of totally hypothesis
free science and I'm sure those people
will debate me on that and I think we
need to worry about hypothesis and past
knowledge --is that we know I don't know
that we have to identify a testable
hypothesis for everything we do but we
certainly need to be documenting what
we're after and how we plan to find it
this is the figure showing the estimates
and what you see in the top plot is the
percent of influenza-like illness --is
and the bottom is just the error between
the two showing the noise around zero
and what you see is starting after after
July 2011 it starts to deviate some more
and then 213 so things like that if we
find a mistake it's not so much pointing
out a mistake and saying that that it's
wrong it's what can we do better with
this so there are several quotes about
learning from mistakes you know anyone
who's never made a mistake has never
learned anything new each mistake should
teach us something and one of my recent
favors is always make new mistakes it's
you should learn from the mistakes you
make but don't be afraid to try new
things and so how do we expand data
science without reinventing the wheel
regarding data challenges some of that
is knowledge and summaries of these so
in order to avoid mistakes and data
science as we expand we should carry an
appreciation for database stumbling
blocks that have been established in the
past and explore how these manifests at
scale and keep an eye out for new sorts
of challenges that may not have been an
issue in older sized data sets but would
be now so I'm going to review for data
analysis issues that remain relevant for
big data but also need to be customized
and refined in the Big Data context
there's a couple important contrast I
want to mention too the first is
observational versus experimental data
and this is where you're taking data
that you are seeing versus data that
comes from in a designed experiment
there was a period of time where the
literature referred to this found data
working in geographic information
systems we do this a lot we'll take the
census
I don't want to map the census regions
because they've already done that I
don't need to reestablish the census
data but I want to link it to new data
and message I tend to give my students
is the data's always looks greener if
you didn't collect them I think we think
that about social media data if you
think about electronic medical records
they include a lot of information but
some of it may be opinion some of it may
not be as good as it sounds
so as we grab observational data to make
decisions one question is does the disk
design mat or should we be hoping for an
experiment or link this to it and does
it even matter I think I gave a big data
talk once where my title was design is
dead long live design and my argument
was we needed to come up with new types
of design to understand the sorts of
studies we were doing that doesn't mean
not to take use of the big data but it's
to try to figure out how to make the
best use of big data so some questions
do data have to come from a design to be
useful I don't think that's necessarily
the case but I think you can gain things
from a design and this data quality
matter if I can get a lot of data this
is another big argument if if I'd like
independent observations that'd be great
that I could take a whole lot of
correlated ones that maybe get the same
information so what do you lose an
observational data at the smaller scale
this is something epidemiologists have
been concerned with for a long time um
one design data about I thought this is
a really nice example that jelly Meng
from Harvard is put together he proposes
an interesting kind of thought
experiment now this isn't a discussion
that the references on the bottom of a
paper by Keating and Lewis on on perils
and pitfalls of self-selected entry into
epidemiologic studies and surveys the
idea of using like web forms a web
recruitment to define your control base
and so on and it raises a lot of
question in there are many pages of
discussion after so if that's an area
you're interested in I think there's a
lot of good information in the article
and a discussion but jowly points out
this example suppose we're interested in
estimating say the average income in the
United States and we had two choices of
datasets one was a
hundred individuals selected a simple
random sample so every individual in the
United States is equally likely to be
selected and would participate or we
could get data from 50 million
individuals but it's not as cleaning
data that there's a correlation between
their income which were interested in
and the probability of being selected
it's not big correlation he was setting
an example of 0.05 so what we're saying
is suppose income was slightly
correlated with the probability of
completing a web survey about your
income and then you want to get the
estimate well 50 million in a hundred
seems like wow that's so big that must
be good enough and main does some
algebra I'm not going to show you but
it's in the discussion that there's
actually more information in the small
sample you need about 62 million to get
the same amount of information so in the
big data setting we do get a lot more
but I think there's a lot of interesting
calculations like this one to be done to
talk about the value and quantity of
information contained in data like that
also in design versus experiment design
experiments allow one to control outside
variables things like temperature or
genetic strain or precipitation that
could have an impact on your outcome but
they're not your primary interest and in
studying flu say if we only took
observations in the summer we would miss
things like the peak that generally
happens in the winter associations with
travel periods and the times when
schools start the design can help remove
things but we also don't want to design
our way around important contributors so
we have observational versus
experimental data we'll be talking
mostly about observational the second
contrast is prediction versus estimation
I'm not going to make a contrast in my
conclusions but I do want to point out
these are different issues and will
bring up both a lot of this discussion
hinges on a paper in 2001 on the two
cultures and statistical modeling that I
think is one of the things that feeds
into data science basic idea is if we
have input these might be predictors
they go into a box something happens in
that box and we observe some output the
two cultures differ and what we're
interested in the prediction group is
giving me a new X can I predict
I really well and I don't really care
what happens in the box I just want to
be able to predict the outcome well this
information side our estimation side is
can I define the associations between x
and y and try to figure out what's
happening inside the box that maybe just
measures of associations like
regressions or logistic regressions or
it may well be something like they know
more advanced machine learning deep
learning or a causal inference so the
distinction between the two is what what
do you care to find out in epidemiology
there's a little bit of both we do want
to predict how many flu cases are
because one it can tell us how to set up
a prevention scheme if we know the types
of strains that can help us plan for
vaccinations but we're also there's a
medical interest in what causes things
to spread and we're interested in what
happens inside the box too because if we
predict well I'd like to know what's in
the box like it changed the outcome so
what can get in the way of doing either
prediction or estimation how do we get
the most out of big data well with
respect to prediction again a Google Flu
Trends is like we didn't really care
that how basketball scores were
associated with flu but we found out
they helped us predict better so that's
a good thing with estimation what can
get in the way is what makes our
estimates wrong and then if they're
biased is bias always a bad thing so
I'll come back to that in a minute these
are the four issues we're going to be
talking about in this context of big
data and data science multiple testing
bias confounding and missing and
mismeasured data so multiple testing and
statistical hypothesis testing has been
a mainstay and for small data analysis
for decades now there's been a lot
written about it it certainly has there
are some legitimate concerns about
turning all of your results down into
his yes-or-no answer but it's still out
there the p-value reports as certainly
something to discuss but you will see a
lot of publications based on that so in
a statistical hypothesis testing setting
you reject the null hypothesis is some
level of statistical significance and
typically this is 0.05 and there's
probably a lot of talks about why five
percents there so this means for each
test there's a 5% chance of rejecting
the null hypothesis when the null
hypothesis was actually true so it's a
false positive result
well it's 5% for each test but if you're
doing a lot of tests what does this mean
so when we're testing a lot of
hypotheses and these might be checking
associations between several outcomes or
several variables you might think of a
gene expression microarray lots and lots
of observations if the tests were
independent of one another then you
would expect one in 20 to yield a false
positive result with this point oh five
level but what if you're testing two
hundred thousand genes the magnitude the
problem that there's a lot of highly
technical statistical calculations you
can do on this to get exactly what it is
but especially if you've got correlation
and independence but the problem remains
how you scale this up so what do you do
some potential solutions then some of
which have been around for a long time
there's bonferroni adjustment if you
have K and dependent test you just
adjust the significance level of each of
the tests by dividing by K so the
overall false positive find a
probability of false finding any false
positives is 5% so it's a very
conservative adjustment and it doesn't
really scale well so if I want to split
up my point oh five across 200,000 tests
I'm talking about a p-value for
significance 0.025 and that's not
particularly meaningful you think about
how much data you would have to collect
to have that kind of precision out in
the tails to be sure that's what your
probability was putting these things
together usually gives a familywize
probability of any false discoveries the
probability that the number of false
discoveries is bigger than 0 and that's
that's served pretty well there's a lot
of literature on multiple comparisons my
own father wrote his dissertation on
multiple comparison issues and there's a
SAS procedure with a Waller option using
his technique but there's scale
abilities a real problem here and 1995
and refined in 2000 then Germany and
Hochberg introduced a concept called the
false discovery rate rather than the
probability of false discoveries now we
often think of rates and probabilities
is similar but there is a key
distinction here that they were making
the false discovery rate is not the
probability of any false discovery it's
the expected fraction of discoveries you
make or any cutoff that our fault
so this is different than what the
bonferroni familywize is doing which is
the probability of the number of having
any false discoveries being bigger than
zero is 0.05 so that Benjamin Hochberg
is saying we think it would be worse to
have four fault discoveries out of ten
than having 20 out of a hundred where
would be one-fifth so it's the rate of
out of how many you detect what fraction
do you think that are false and this is
fundamentally kind of a different way of
thinking about it but one that scales
much much better and so there's been
widespread use of the false discovery
rate especially in the genetics and
genomics literature and there's a lot of
resources for exactly how to calculate
the false discovery rate I'm not going
to talk about those here today so we can
talk about the other topics but it's an
excellent illustration of how an
inferential idea things like false
discoveries and type 1 error rates
needed to be rethought to scale to the
big data setting so we had an adequate
solution of small scale but it didn't
extend so the addressing the issue
required backing up a little bit to that
in the whirling vortex what question do
we really want to answer here and kind
of starting from those ideas again
there's a really nice FDR overview and
some slides that Christian avicii has
posted that I used to help summarize
some of the results above so moving on
to bias from the multiple testing the
quintessential example of anyone
teaching bias and variability I know
this is the case in public health and
probably a lot of various is this sort
of 4 targets here you're shooting arrows
at the target upper left we've got low
bias and low variability where we
average out there in the bullseye and
they're not very far apart moving to the
right we're still averaging out near the
bull's eye but there's a lot more spread
in a single shot maybe further away
bottom left we've got high bias and low
variability we keep hitting the same
spot but we're off consistently by some
amount and the last one we're not close
to the bull's eye and we're not very
consistent so high bias high variability
so there's this connection with bias and
variability is an important one I'd like
to keep talking about but first this is
the New Yorker cartoon version of that
there's something called the Texas
sharpshooter approach where you shoot
the side
the barn and paint a bull's-eye around
and this is the medieval version or
you've got someone to do the painting
for you
so some bias we live with every day so
those of you who are parents probably
have used an ear thermometer or those of
you just don't like having a thermometer
and your tongue may have used an ear
thermometer they don't give you the same
number
they both better measure body
temperature and they're both pretty
reliable they have smaller variability
and you get the similar answers as long
as you use it right but they're not
centered in the same place in this case
there's low variability
you've got reproducible bias but we can
correct for the bias of the simple
adjustment in the case of the
thermometers we kind of memorize what
normal is on either one and then if
you're taking your child's temperature
you're also trying to remember is this
do they seem well enough to go to school
or not um bias and variability come
together and they're there there's this
bias variability trade-off in a lot of
statistics books and one of these is if
you're talking about the mean squared
error of prediction how well are you
doing one summary of that is taking the
expected value of the difference between
your prediction and the truth what
you're predicting squaring that that's
called the mean squared error and doing
some algebra you find this is the sum of
two things it's the variance of your
prediction plus the square of the bias
of your prediction how far you're off so
if bias goes down variance can go up for
the mean squared error can still stay
the same say accuracy of your prediction
is a function of both a variability of
your prediction and the squared bias in
your prediction this is an old
statistical idea and it carries in a lot
of settings and sometimes you can reduce
the variance by incorporating a little
bias so Tom Lewis has a nice essay on
bias isn't necessarily a bad thing
as long as you have some control over it
if it helps rain things in this is an
element of a lot of Bayesian methods
which induce some bias but they actually
add precision and they borrow
information across datasets I think last
week Michael Newton's bd2k seminar on
Bayesian statistics gave some overview
of this but if you look at borrowing
information you'll see how a biased
[Music]
estimate can actually give you some
improvement over an unbiased one let's
an example of linear regression a lot of
times when you are talking to your
regression you're told that ordinary
least squares estimates are unbiased and
then ordinary least squares you're
trying to pick some parameters beta to
minimize the difference between the
regression model the X beta minus the
observations Y squared and it's unbiased
but there's an important caveat to that
it's only unbiased if we have all the
right covariates in the model and I put
this simple regression picture up here
that I've made up because when I took a
regression class they told us how to
build a least square machine I thought
this was a cool idea if I it would be
hard to scale this up though but if I
had a Board of wood and I nailed in
nails where all my points were and I had
a stick and I had rubber bands from each
point and I have to make sure the rubber
bands are going up and down with the Y
direction but you snap it the stick that
the equilibrium point where all the
pressure is on the stick will land on
the least squares regression line so
let's think about that all of those
points are pulling on it with the
Rubberbandits so it's going to end up in
the middle and it's trying to have the
minimum total tension in the rubber
bands but suppose we really needed X 1
and X 2 so rather than just a single
line there's this plane and it's the way
I've tried to draw this is there's a
negative slope going down in the X 2
direction and they get a slope in the Y
direction but it kind of slopes you can
see we've got clouds of points around it
so suppose we really needed X 1 and X 2
to do this but we only if we only
observe X 1 I'm going to back up one
slide it's like we're taking a
flashlight shining it down on the X 1 Y
plane
all those points are going to put their
shadows there these grey lines I have
the solid grade lines are kind of the
lines in my plane just to show the
different groups the different parts of
X 1 and X 2 but that you really wouldn't
see that and if you fit a regression
line let's say it's this dashed line
here it may be unbiased but there's an
awful lot of noise around it as opposed
to the amount of noise that would have
been around the plane so it could it
might be unbiased but noisier but
suppose we didn't get to see all of the
X 2s and there was some change in
whether they were included
so I'm only including the ones in the
circle now which means for the low ex
ones
I only saw low ex ones for the x2 so the
non solvent ones get left out and if you
notice the the bars the bar for x2 out
here is the higher values of x2 I pick
the low ones and for the higher values
of x2 I picked the high x ones now I
would get a line that goes in the
completely other direction so there's a
sampling bit if there are changes in the
chance of things being included it can
bias our results and it can do it quite
a bit so what happened it turned out x2
contained important information we
needed to consider in this case it had
information about what values of x1 were
included in the data set we got to see
and the result is a biased estimate of
the true association between X 1 and Y
so this is one type of bias that can
result in observational studies if we
don't control for the value of x2 but it
had an influence on what we were seeing
then our resulting estimates would be
changed now this is a sort of an example
of confounding confounding is a big word
in epidemiology and or confounding it's
brought up in big data analysis often
rothman and Greenland describe it as a
and the control confusion of effects an
example above X 2 was confounding the
effect of X 1 because X 2 is controlling
which values of X 1 we saw now
confounding and I've written
encyclopedia entries on confounding and
every time I do I get a headache because
it's not easy to define mathematically
there's no single mathematical
definition or statistics statistical
definition so it's hard to develop some
sort of test or solution but it is a
conceptual meaning we we all understand
it's it's an effect that would confound
the one we're interested in so if we
were looking at associations with
smoking and lung cancer age might be a
confounder there may be a birth cohort
confounding in terms of level of smoking
so the concepts familiar there's always
room for sensitivity analysis with
confounding you can find you can try to
include potential confounders and see
whether your results change when you add
them or take them out of
your analysis and I think this is a
particularly important contribution of
the subject matter part of the Venn
diagram for data science because there
are often established sets of potential
confounders for particular outcomes and
the epidemiology literature if you don't
control for age and race the referees
are going to ask you why you didn't do
it so you could even check and not have
it make a difference and leave it out
you will still be asked about it because
so many health effects vary with age so
many health affects our health
disparities are observed in different
race groups and smoking has always had a
big influence - so this is I'd encourage
you to think about it but like I said
I've been thinking about it for 30 years
and it still is hard to get a handle on
now I need to click and here we go
what another example of expression array
and this is this came up in Rafah
Irizarry bd2k webinar which is archived
he was looking at gene expression arrays
and talking about batch effects when
gene expression arrays first came out it
was amazing thing he could measure it
you know responsiveness in multiple
genes at once and so his his experiment
here he's discussing or the example he's
talking about is suppose you're
comparing gene expression array results
and you have some of your gene
expressions are from tumor cells and
some of the genes are from non tumor
cells but you sent it to the lab in two
batches and let's say they ran all the
tumor samples on Friday that everyone
left for the weekend it came back and
around the tumor cells the non tumor
cells on Monday and if you see a
difference in the expression between the
different genes you're investigating
what does it mean well we'd like to
think it means a tune or non tumor
difference but it may well be a day of
processing difference it may take a
while he at the lab set up again on
Monday or we may not have things turned
on and warmed up or if if that's this is
sort of a design issue behind even
observational study so one of the things
you would see in the evolution of
publication about microarray analysis or
gene expression analysis was an
introduction of adding replicates and
starting to look for some of these
confounders so if you're interested in
more of that example rafa's eras are
east
bd2k seminar does a nice job of walking
through that and showing a lot of
examples last area I want to talk about
is missing data so what have you're
missing outcome values for some
predictors or what if you're missing
predictor values for some outcomes
should you ignore it I mean this is a
this becomes a frequent if not
ubiquitous issue in in connecting large
data sets is that you won't have all the
pieces should you ignore it should you
plug in a reasonable number so you just
put in the mean and hope for the best
these are all things that are done
sometimes and I think we've all thought
about if you're missing the outcome one
algorithm that's seen wide use on the
smaller scale and we have to see how it
scales up is something called the e/m
algorithm the expectation maximization
algorithm so suppose you're missing a
few of your outcomes variables but you
have the X's you have the predictor
values in your regression model so I'll
show some graphs of what this looks like
the algorithm are these algorithms
iterate between filling in the missing
information based on your current
current analysis you're currently fitted
model and then refitting the model and
then updating your estimates and so on
until this converges so in a regression
setting we might have the following
let's say we have the observed dots but
the two I've circled we didn't really
get to see the Y values so I know what
the X values are those are the dotted
the dashed lines there but I don't know
what the Y value is now if I knew the
right answer I should get the gray
dashed line but if I leave these two out
I get a bias I get an orange the orange
graphed line so the estep is on the left
and the m-step is on the right the East
step you would replace the Miss you
assign the missing values the
expectation from the orange line this is
what we think these two Y values should
be if the model was right then the M
step is to put those values in and
recalculate the orange lines so it moves
over in this case it got closer to the
grey line and then you'd kind of iterate
back and forth with these you'd be
updating what you think Y is and
updating what your estimate is and under
pretty broad conditions this will
converge to the right answer
so again just
the estep is expected values the m-step
is refit the model with its dated
guesses for missing data and your peat
oak emergence now I'm sure this has been
scaled to Big Data and distributed
computing but trying to take the
algorithm and break it down in a way
that could go off of distributed
processors and so on
it has has a lot of a lot of validity
and a lot of interest now if the color
rates are missing what do we do to
ignore them we've already seen that
ignoring x2 in our example earlier led
to confounding and bias because it was
important could we impute a value or
make a guess what if we could guess a
lot of values would that would be value
in that well multiple imputation is an
area that's been used a lot in smaller
data analysis but and has some
similarities to cross validation that
gets used a lot in big data analysis
it's just not they're not doing exactly
the same thing what multiple imputation
does is for every missing value you
simulate multiple values and then even
even even doing two or three for each
one rather than just one allows you to
estimate the missing value itself and
the variability in that missing value so
you're not guessing it perfectly but
you're going to have to guess it with
some variation and then percolate that
variation through to your model so the
imputed value is inform us on the
overall variability of our estimate or
prediction and they take into account
the extra variability we've added by
putting our imputation in so this
requires a model for a mutation how
would you impute it how often would you
impute and the little and Rubin book is
really the standard for both e/m
algorithm then and multiple imputation I
also like Schafer's book even though
this is it's been out quite a while
there may be a second addition to this
and seeing how some of these ideas could
be played out in the big data setting I
think would be incredibly valuable so
just to wrap up and it will leave us
some time for questions if any have come
in multiple testing the main issue is if
we take a lot of things we need to
control for the impact of false
positives so what do we do about this we
should always worry about multiple
testing I mean I don't say you should
not
to it but you should be somewhat
concerned and maybe feel a little bad
about it
but you know the idea is like false
discovery rate in similar summaries are
gaining a lot of ground there there
we've got a better understanding of them
and and it involved backing up to the
basic ideas and building something that
was more extendable and bias is what the
issue is the estimates differ from the
true values and what we should do of
course we should worry about that we
should document and adjust if possible
is my ear and mouth thermometer example
but also trying to get you know in a
more general sense trying to model the
observation process try to think about
how we see the data we see how that can
have an influence on this so I really
think that subject matter component is
important in data science it's not just
a calculation and then hope the numbers
are right so I think there's a lot of
work to do on thinking about bias and
again tied into the Bayesian estimation
it provides a way to borrow information
that may be a little biased but it may
improve our precision with confounding
we've got a factor outside of our
analysis impacting our results again
what we should do is worry and
epidemiology articles are particularly
good at thinking about ways that the
observational conclusions may be may be
wrong and how to prove it better
I think sensitivity analyses are always
a good idea in terms of checking the
impact of things now on on a large big
data setting we might not have the
flexibility for say simulations that we
do on a smaller scale but we might want
to think about ways to look for evidence
you know what Wake does confounding
leave in your data
it's also important to catalog the
common confounders in a certain area of
application we shouldn't be doing
analyses de novo in every setting and we
should learn from the past I think this
is one of the points that the laser a
tall article was making about the flu
trends it's fine to make mistakes but we
also don't need to do our analysis
completely oblivious of what people know
about this area or about the data types
finally with missing data the issues the
data are not complete this is not a
surprise to anyone but
again we should worry about it not just
brush it under the rug especially
documenting the reason it's missing I
gave you an example with my confounder
where I had missing data is on x2 that
impacted the estimate of x1 and that's
because the probability of being
included was related to the outcome I
was looking at you have a lot less bias
if that problem missing missing this
mechanism is random data missing
completely at random or a little more
generally missing at random it won't
infect your results as much there are
things like the e/m algorithm imputation
but I do think there's a lot of work
there to think about scaling those up
into more general tools and having them
fit into the data scientist toolbox and
model missingness I think there's a lot
of room for explaining why the data are
missing that may actually be the first
round of analysis you do if in my
example there was an indication that x2
had an impact on whether the value of x2
that an impact on whether x1 was
observed and if you can understand and
model the missingness this might help
untangle the effects it has so just
bring this all together data and
analysis issues that come from
Statistics and epidemiology of
biostatistics like before we talked
about today all have deep backgrounds at
standard size analysis but they may not
scale directly to the big data setting
and I think this is a very interesting
area for collaborations between the
large scale data scientist interest and
people trained in statistics and
epidemiology so these aren't issues that
one can avoid so that I wasn't being
totally facetious about saying worry
about everything and like worry is
essential to doing good work the
bonferroni and false discovery rate
example illustrates how addressing data
issues in a big data setting can require
rethinking even basic assumptions it
didn't say the assumptions were wrong it
just said the relevant proportion we
were interested in was different than
what the Bron Peroni had been adjusting
so there's a lot of background within
each of the three or seven or however
many elements of the Venn diagram but I
think the most interesting research it
as occur in the overlap and that's where
I think data science will kind of come
into its own so I really like the idea
of team data science and having
different skill sets available and as a
great framework for addressing this I
think it's more interesting to have a
statistician and a computer scientist in
the room both thinking about the same
problem rather than having them work
separately and then present their
solutions to each other so I would say
let's go forward and make new mistakes
together and I believe we have some time
for questions fantastic lecture lands
thank you so much we do want to
encourage people to write in their
questions and as people are putting
fingers two keys I had a couple of
questions and I thought these are sort
of big questions and I wanted to just
kind of get your thoughts on these you
had mentioned one thing in some of your
introductory remarks and the couple of
remarks he had made and one of them
involved an interesting term which I
thought was was I don't know kind of
caught my attention that was of data
hubris big data hubris and you can kind
of understand that lots of people think
oh if we just have more data the answers
will be in there and when we've got all
these methods and techniques to go and
just ferret them out and we'll just know
everything and the hubris element of
that I find to be somewhat fascinating I
think one of the more recent examples of
this everybody's kind of aware of and I
don't mean to get political here but was
in the recent us kind of elections where
it was clear that one candidate was
everyone was predicting that that
candidate was totally I was going to
walk away with the election and then on
the given night everyone was a little
surprised at how that turned out and I'm
curious if you had any thoughts about
you know whether or not there was any
bias or variance in the prophecies that
led up to that somewhat surprising
outcome well I'd say the kind of
ubiquity and ease of doing a survey that
may not be a scientific sample survey I
think that the polls and so on really
took a hit I don't know if other people
are like me but I'm getting multiple
calls at dinner
now that are you know recorded surveys
on how's the government doing and in in
my heart is a statistician I want to
supply data but you know in my head I
also realized these are all paid for by
different groups and the wording of the
questions are looking one way or the
other and so I think that it was a lot
of with a diversifies news media and
everything there was they know what will
play to their audience and so questions
were asked in a certain way I don't
think there was as much pooling of the
information across the serbia I mean if
there's a very complicated setting
there's a lot written about like
Facebook and the kind of divergent you
have your group of friends and use for
word articles that tell you kind of the
same thing we're all sort of in our own
bubbles
I think 538 tries to do a good job of
that but you've got all this information
in 538 worked really well the last
couple of elections because it was based
on polls that had measures of
uncertainty and that's what it's good at
doing putting them together but if the
questions are leading in the your
probability my probability of
participating is not equal for every
poll and I am frustrated by that but I
also I'm reacting just like a lot of
other people are that I may only be
answering polls that kind of cater to
what I hope and I think in that setting
then a poll doesn't work anymore so that
there is kind of this idea that having a
lot of data but finding that it's the
people who respond and that's why the
model that modeling the missingness is
really important and understanding where
it comes from so going back to that data
analysis whirling vortex you know
knowing what data you would like to get
and how that differs from the data that
you can get or you ultimately get and
what question you did answer with your
data I think we assumed we were
answering a question about who's going
to win the election but we were actually
answering questions about who's who's
ahead in the minds of those who respond
to this particular once we start putting
all the caveats in there we start
realizing we answered a much more
specific question than the general one
we were interested in
so one of our listeners writes in and
they're asking about the
expectation-maximization methodology and
whether or not the iterations that you
use to fill in the missing data how
often does that lead to a wrong model
does that make sense and so why not just
ignore those points you go through this
big thing and it converges on something
you think Oh Eureka there's my model but
in fact it's an in fact wrong often
states it has a good it has a pretty
general set of regularity conditions the
conditions under which it does what it's
supposed to do and converges to the
right answer
it won't converge to as precise an
answer then if you had all the data
because there's some uncertainty in
those missing pieces but it should move
in the right direction there's a fair
amount of literature on the just for
lack of a better term long a small data
setting of its performance and how well
it works you know I think one of the
biggest questions for some of these
statistical techniques and rolling them
out to the big data setting is can you
could you distribute it and put it back
together so there's a it's it's sort of
like MapReduce except it's doing the
analysis on that so that's the oh
there's used to be had a different name
but built Chambers is doing a lot of
this of what kind of statistical
algorithms can be broken into pieces
that they can be sent off to different
processors and then recombined in such a
way that you keep the answer so I think
that's a very active area for work it's
wide open for good ideas and I think you
know that's an area where paring the
statistical researcher a methodologist
with a computer scientist could lead to
some big improvements in both areas and
that the you know the joint improvement
of both areas is where data science gets
better
great the another question I I had was I
see amongst a lot of younger
investigators some of the postdoctoral
fellows that I've encountered there
seems to be a particular I don't know
particular value put on finding evarin
Moore's
smaller p-values and so you know
somebody will go find something that's
you know one times ten to the negative
sixteenth and get very very excited
because well it's much better than you
know one times ten to the negative
fourth and so they think it's more
important and they make the classic
mistake I think of mistaking statistical
significance with practical and
theoretical significance you know they
may only be accounting for like 3% of
the variance but it's wildly significant
because they've got big data what sort
of message can we kind of convey to
people to maybe avoid some of the issues
that come up when you fall into that
sort of traffic that makes sense yeah I
mean I think the easy trap to following
with p-values is the smaller one must be
more significant and you know one of the
things there's been some pushback some
journals won't accept p-values anymore
and I think part of that is because
there's I think p-values serve a purpose
by themselves but I think they're
they're overused and over-interpreted
and this is one example in which that
happens you know even if the null
hypothesis is true the actual p-value
you get should be uniformly distributed
between 0 & 1 so you know ranking them
if you're not rejecting doesn't make
sense and then the distribution shifts
I'm saying a lot of words what I what I
think would be helpful is if we start
thinking about you know measures of
Association and then bringing in the
subject matter aspect of the Venn
diagram is the difference we saw really
meaningful because there's it can be
statistical significance but the
difference you actually detected was
kind of small you know I don't like to
see these p-value contests like you said
I think that's putting too much emphasis
on something that's hard to estimate and
to me a p-value of 10 to the minus 6 I
don't even know what that means because
I've never really observed too many
things with a million observations to
get this you know one in a million and
if you get these really tiny ones you
know it
I think weird things happen and that we
don't appreciate that even though it had
a small probability it still could
happen yeah I
agree I find that you know when people
who said in certain areas of big data
research start talking about p-values
that are you know 10 to the minus 16 or
something they're down in the machine
precision Oh in that you know errors is
you just can't trust anything that gets
that low and the emphasis being on the
p-value I think is somewhat misguided
and I'm not quite sure how that happened
because I was always kind of brought up
to think how much how much of the
variance am i accounting for for example
you know that give me a sense of how
strong my model is and that ends up not
being very important to some people and
you know maybe I missed a memo but it
seems that that's sample of you know
data science is a new field with people
coming from other fields and that's why
I was talking about a team data science
because this concepts that you carry
with you or sort of what you trained to
look for what was that what was
important about doing the analysis and
having people with the different
perspectives I think is a broader image
of that and so you know there's people
who think all of statistics is and what
they get in one class similarly there's
people who think all of computer science
is what they got in one class and we
really need to recognize that's not the
case and it's very hard to be an expert
at both of them but you can learn a lot
of Pete in them if they're getting
together and working together so I think
data science is a highly collaborative
field I like to think of statistics is
highly collaborative but data science I
think is even often even more so and
it's a combination of people with
different intuitions expertise
experience kind of default assumptions
and that's where I think we can sort a
lot of things out with these kind of
collaborations and conversations I'm
really glad to hear you say that because
my kind of last question I had was how
can we help universities and university
administrators kind of understand that
that team data science is important it's
not just statistics it's not just
computer science that you your most
universities already have but it's
something that's unique and special how
can we help them to recognize that I
think it's good to highlight
the successes in places that are that
had a lot of universities develop
Institutes of data science for instance
some of those institutes are within
computer science or they're within
another field but I think they're really
strongest ones and the ones that I think
are making the biggest difference but
will ultimately and I hope this is the
case continue to make a big difference
will be the ones that have this
interdisciplinary feel and I have gone
to a lot of Statistics conferences where
people say well are we data scientists
that was the early conversation the
conversation I heard last week at a
statistics conference was we're part of
an institute and we have a track on
statistical methodology or a track on
health analytics because we work in a
lot of Health area we can help put the
algorithms in perspective and what kind
of questions they can answer we sort of
established some not standards but usual
ways of doing things to me that was it I
think that's a big development because
it that would argue against having a
Center for data science inside a
Statistics Department or a center for
data science inside a computer science
department without talking to each other
so you know I think as we see
developments happen that have benefited
from the inner core interdisciplinary
collaboration I think that's where it
will really that's its kind of hate to
wait for that to happen but I think
that's where the big the big
developments will be and so as those
happen and also you know I am a little
afraid that some of the purely
algorithmic approaches are going to make
some big mistakes somewhere and maybe
it's not just guessing how many people
had flu last week maybe it's predicting
drugs for a can't you know drug
assignment for cancer in precision
medicine if you use a machine learning
algorithm works really well for getting
pretty good increase in your profit in a
business setting and you apply that to
you know blindly as a black box and I
don't know if anyone would do that but
suppose you did to defining that you may
get 90% of the things right but you've
got 10% of patients who are getting the
wrong dose and that could be fatal it
could be costly so some of this is you
know I think statisticians are sort of
inbred
worriers because of variance and we
think about what kind of all that kind
of errors we can make we give them names
type 1 type 2 errors we need to develop
kind of what can go wrong and that's why
are these four topics came up today well
let me thank you on behalf of all of our
listeners today for your fantastic talk
dr. Weller thank you very very much once
again we'll be having another one of
these next Friday at 9:00 a.m. Pacific
and noon Eastern and we look forward to
seeing you all again then thank you
again dr. Waller thank you very much